I don't overreact to a lot of stuff
because that is the best way to be I'm
not saying to be a robot I'm not saying
you should have no emotion to me you
should never show any I'm not saying
that but you should have some control
over those emotions especially from a
leadership perspective when somebody
says something to you that's traumatic
or is gonna cause a disturbance or it's
gonna cause problems immediately things
yourself
okay picture that you're being recorded
and you're gonna have to watch the
play-by-play later with your team and
look at what how much you lost your
temper or how much you've got frazzled
and what it is asking for I'm just gonna
listen assess make decisions